قال رئيس وزراء كوسوفو لحكومته ستقف بحزم
في وجه من وصفهم بالمستبدين من امثال رئيس
صربيا واضاف كرسي في مقابله خاصه مع
الجزيره على مجتمع الصربيه في كوسوفو لا
يشارك عموما في الاضطرابات التي شهدتها
بلديات في شمالي البلاد مؤكدا ان من يقف
وراءها ميليشيات فاشيه عنيفه مرتبطه
تعبيره
انا ادافع عن بلدي والجمهوريه الديمقراطيه
لا يمكن ان تنحني
لا اسعى الى المساواه بين من يقفون وراء
هذه الاحداث العنيفه وبين المجتمع السربي
الذي لا يشارك عموما في الاضطرابات التي
شهدناها في هذه البلديات اعتقد اننا يجب
ان نقف معا وبحزم في وجه المستبدين من
امثال رئيس الجاره الشماليه لكوسوفو صربيا
بدلا من محاوله استرضائهم لان كل كرم اظهر
حتى الان اسيء فهمه واعتبر ضعفا وخوفا